Robert Clem Cove he's a writer for
Sports Illustrated the MQB and his most
recent column is there's more history to
Antonio Browns history and Robert joins
us now what do we know about what
happened yesterday with Antonio Browns
accuser meeting with the NFL you know
just that they met you know I don't know
that it was ever even reported what time
they met they kept it pretty strictly
under wraps she has managed this ever
since she went public very well in my
mind in a sense that she hasn't done any
extra media and she went straight to the
league and cooperated with them and and
that's something that they've had
trouble with in the past trying to get
two accusers who aren't a part of
criminal charges but do have public or
reported accusations they've had
difficulty getting ahold of some of
these women but she made herself
accessible and I think that you know
there won't be any immediate decisions
but they're gonna sit around and talk
about whether or not they found her
credible Sports Illustrated conducted
interviews with more than two dozen
people who have employed worked for
coached or played alongside Brown some
who have taken legal action against him
and others who have not why no criminal
charges against Antonio Brown so a lot
of these people say that Antonio Brown
owes them you know in the hundreds of
dollars or the low thousands you know
seven hundred bucks two thousand dollars
owed to a guy he had install 220 gallon
fish tank full of piranhas seven hundred
dollars for a charity that he stole a
painting of himself from allegedly
according to all these people and so
they're filing small claims in in civil
court hoping that these things get
resolved because they're suing somebody
who's worth sixty nine million dollars I
think that you will see eventually
criminal charges filed against him in
any number of these cases if they don't
ever come to terms with these people but
I can't imagine that Antonio Brown would
let it get to that why was he reportedly
in the middle of negotiations with this
accuser
who accused him of rape sexual assault
that they were trying to settle on
something
why was he settling if he's completely
innocent well I mean you know innocent
people settle in lawsuits all the time I
don't think that's indication that he's
definitely guilty but they did have a
deal on the table to settle for two
million dollars and at the last minute
he backed away you know I think it kind
of speaks to this idea that Antonio was
a little bit out on an island at this
point in his career in his life you know
we talked to people who were considered
mentors who had kept in touch with him
for his entire NFL career who hadn't
spoken to him in months
he's a little bit off the grid right now
and I think that his behavior over the
last three years has to be a product of
that yeah I was talking to a source this
a couple of days ago who works inside
the NFL and his is privately worried
about his mental like his state of mind
here and you know because I said is this
a brand and he just decided that he
wants to be bigger and he's not just a
football player and you know all these
things and this person who knows him
says I am privately worried that there
is more to this than anybody has you
know come to that conclusion with
Antonio Brown most of the people that do
him in high school and in college did
and felt like there had to be way more
to the story than was being indicated
you know I covered the NFL for six years
you know I've been around a few star
players and kind of understood these
little entourage is that they have and
how quickly they can change you know you
might replace the marketing person or
you might replace a personal assistant
but I've never seen the kind of turnover
that it looks like Antonio Brown has had
in terms of friends assistants and the
various people in his orbit the only
constant seems to be jury rosenhouse and
I think that's because drew has taken a
role of you do what you do and then I'll
try to fix it eventually as opposed to
trying to be more involved in trying to
give Antonio Brown advice
which is honestly something he needs do
you think more likely that he continues
to play and this is I guess you know
maybe not fair to ask you but he
continues to play commissioners exempt
or he gets suspended you know I think it
depends on what else comes out you know
after we wrote our story yesterday on on
this second sexual misconduct accuser
and then also details with all these
people who are suing him we had three
more people reach out to say Antonio
Brown owes me money and so obviously you
know we don't know if any of those
people are credible I don't know if I'm
going to do a follow-up story or not but
I think that they're going to be people
coming out of the woodwork with Antonio
Brown stories piling on for lack of a
better word and the NFL is going to have
to decide you know when is enough enough
and and and frankly the Patriots will
have to decide
can we actually keep this person from
embarrassing us for the next six months
because you know I don't think they have
to worry about the offseason you know I
think they have a plan for that I think
they can cut ties with him if they feel
like he's not stable enough but the
question is whether or not he's stable
enough to handle the next five six
months in the building any chance of
talking to his accuser you know I think
that their strategy
ever since the the failed lawsuit is to
find the right venue to drop this story
which they did to talk to the NFL to try
to put pressure on Antonio Brown which
they did and I think they'll go dark at
this point Robert good to talk to you
there was a great reporting on this
story there's more history to Antonio
Browns history it's on the mmq be great
to talk to you
thank you that's Robert Clint go for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]